Despite spending the last decade or so of
his career often injured, Ken Griffey Jr.
was a 13-time All-Star, a 10-time Gold Glove
winner, a 7-time Silver Slugger award winner,
1997 MVP, 6th all-time in career home runs
with 630, and he accumulated nearly 80 WAR
(more on “WAR” in the Bonus Facts below).
Any number you look at, it’s clear Ken Griffey
Jr., nicknamed “The Kid,” was one of the
greatest players ever to step onto a baseball
field.
He became a superstar when he was only 19
years old, starting in center field for the
Seattle Mariners in 1989.
But just because someone is successful, famous,
and rich (it’s estimated he made over $150
million during his playing career) doesn’t
mean they can’t be sad or, even, depressed.
After becoming one of the biggest can’t-miss
prospects in baseball history, at the age
of 18 the man who would not only be known
for that beautiful swing, but also for his
infectious and seemingly constant smile, attempted
suicide.
Ken Griffey Jr. grew up in a baseball-centric
household.
His father, Ken Griffey Sr., was a very good
Major Leaguer in his own right.
A three-time All-Star, Griffey Sr. was probably
most well-known for being an integral part
of the 1970s Cincinnati Reds, who were nicknamed
“The Big Red Machine” and won back to
back World Series titles in 1975 and 1976.
“Junior,” as his dad’s teammates came
to know the younger Griffey as, was often
around the Reds’ clubhouse during these
years.
Johnny Bench, the Reds’ Hall of Fame catcher,
once said (jokingly) in an ESPN chat that
he saw Junior “stealing stuff out of my
locker when he was 8.”
Despite his apparent closeness with his father,
they fought a lot, according to Junior.
“It seemed like my father and I were always
fighting,” Junior said in a 1992 interview.
“I know a lot of kids go through that with
their families, but it was hard for me.”
Junior also said that both he and his father
were stubborn and intense, both good traits
to have as professional athletes, but not
always good when it comes to two such people’s
personal relationship.
On June 2nd, 1987, the Seattle Mariners made
Ken Griffey Jr. the first pick of that year’s
baseball amateur draft.
Junior was only 17 years old at the time of
the draft and was the first son of a Major
Leaguer to ever have been drafted first overall.
The pressure on Junior was immense.
Bob Harrison, a senior scout for the Mariners
at the time, wrote in his scouting report
that “He’s the best I ever seen…. has
all the tools to be a superstar.”
Right away, he dominated the Minor Leagues,
putting him on the fast track to the majors.
Despite playing well, his personal life was
in disarray.
He was living away from home for the first
time and didn’t know how to be a professional.
“He had no supervision,” said Ken Griffey
Sr. in a 1992 interview, “I had people tell
me what he was going through, keeping late
hours and all, very late hours.”
In addition, he encountered things he never
had to deal with growing up in an affluent
household.
There was an incident in Bellingham, Washington
where he was called racial slurs and was chased
with a gun.
In addition, he felt like no matter what he
did on the field, his coaches were always
criticizing him.
In every sense, Junior was being forced to
become an adult when he was still only “The
Kid.”
When he came home for his first offseason
as a professional ball player, he moved back
in with his parents.
Things were not smooth there either.
“It seemed like everyone was yelling at
me in baseball, then I came home and everyone
was yelling at me there,” Griffey recalled
in 1992, “I got depressed.
I got angry.
I didn’t want to live.”
In January 1988, Junior swallowed nearly 300
aspirin in a suicide attempt, something that
could indeed have resulted in his death.
According to Dr. Larry Pedegana, one of the
Mariners’ doctors at the time, “ingesting
a lot of aspirin will cause metabolic acidosis,
which can be fatal.”
Jr. was found covered in vomit in his car
by his girlfriend and her brother.
He was rushed to the hospital by his girlfriend’s
mother, where his stomach was immediately
pumped.
He would remain in the intensive care unit
at Providence Hospital in Mount Airy, Ohio
for several days.
Senior later admitted that he was “scared,
even angry” at his son for his suicide attempt.
In fact, when Senior came and visited Junior
at the hospital, they once again began arguing.
“I ripped the IV out of my arm,” Junior
said in the ‘92 interview.
“That stopped him yelling.”
Junior got better and his relationship with
his father improved.
“The problem was with me and my father…
There weren’t any deep problems with me
afterwards,” Junior stated in a 1992 interview.
Junior was in the Majors the next season,
1989, starting in center field for the Seattle
Mariners.
On August 29th, 1990, the Seattle Mariners
signed Ken Griffey Senior, at the age of 40,
to a contract for the remainder of the season.
Two days later, on August 31st, Junior and
Senior became the first father-son combo to
play in the same Major League game.
On September 14th, in a game against the California
Angels (who ended up winning the game 7-5),
Ken Griffey Sr. strode to the plate in the
bottom of the 1st and promptly drove a two
strike pitch into the stands.
Junior was the next hitter and he waited for
three balls before he slammed the next offering
out of the park.
Junior and Senior had hit back to back home
runs, claiming another distinction in baseball
history as the only father-son combo to hit
back to back homers.
Ken Griffey Jr. retired from baseball during
the 2010 season, one of the legends of baseball.
Today, he works for Mariners as a special
consultant, working with Minor Leaguers on
their defensive skills.
He’s also a dad to three children.
None of which would have happened had his
suicide attempt been successful.
Junior later stated:
Don’t ever try to commit suicide…
Talk to people.
Go another way.
Don’t kill yourself.
It ain’t worth it and I’m a great example…
I am living proof how stupid it is….
No matter how bad it seems at the time, work
your way through it.
Who knows how your life is going to turn out?